On a rencontré notamment un ami
de l'un de ses employés.- - - M.
- Viateur Lamarche est âgé
de 84 ans. Il y a encore
l'entreprise familiale Propane
Lafortune, où il a passé près
de 18 ans.
VIATEUR LAMARCHE, ancien employé
de Propanes s s s s s s s s s s,
mais t'sais, à un moment donné,
j'imaginpapapas que ça pouvait
un jour arriver.
- Après avoir entendu
l'ext t t t t t t t t t t t t té
de joindre par téléphone
l'une des employés.
- Puis elle, elle ne mendndndndt
répondu, parce qu'avec son
cellulaire...
- Cette employée, qu'il connait
personnes qui manquent
àelelelel.
- C'est un femme qui était
vraiment tranquille, qui disait.
ÉLOÏSE COSSETTE,ûûûûreté du Quéc
- Le travail d'expertise de la
scène va durer plusieurs jourlo,
les policiers travaillent
sans relâche, même si la neige
complique les recherches.
- C'est envisagé que demn n n nu
pour protéger l'intégrité
de la scène.
- En matinée, le ministre
sur les lieux de la tragéd
pour constater les dégâts.
FRANÇOIS BONNARDEL,lilililililic
- C'est une scène qui est
difficile à voir.
Si la communauté ici, monsieurn
de quoique,,,,,
le gouvernement sera présent.
- Isab
copropriétaire de l'entreprise,
s'esenenenenent adressé
aux médias dans un message
ISABELLE LAFORTUNE,
copropriétaire Propane Lafortune
- C'est une épreuve extrêmement
difficile pour nous, c'est
L'enquête va nous permettre
d'en apprendre davantage
allons continuer de collaborer
avec les autorités.
la voie criminelle ou suspecte,
mais je peux pas m
davantage sur des causes.
SÉBASTIEN MARCIL, maire de
- C'est très difficile ce qui
se vit actuercrcrcrcrcrce qu'il
y a de l'attente et l'attente
elle est longue.
les résidents sont encore
profonananananananlés.
- C'est une communauté assez
tissé serré, là... règle s s s ,
fait que... non, c'est sûr
que ça va laisser une trace.
- D'après moi, là, dans St-Rochi
n'ffffffffffffaire chez Claude
Lafortune. Que ce soit de c c ct
l l l l l l le propane.
- Même si tout indique qu'ilagae
est maintenant ent
de la division des Crimes
majeurs de la SQ
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada,
à Saint-Roch-de-l'Achigan